Greetings, everybody.
My name is Sam Deiter, and I'm a senior Unreal Engine
instructor with Epic Games.
In the following video tutorial series,
we're going to be taking a look at Blueprints
and Interactions.
And this is going to involve us first recapping
some object-oriented concepts, as understanding this
is vital to being successful with any type of Blueprint
you are having to be creating, where they're
going to talk about controller and pawn classes, what they
are, what they're needed for, and why
we need two different classes in order to interact with users.
We're then going to look at working
with Blueprint interfaces.
Blueprint interfaces are a very cheap, but more importantly,
efficient way to interact or talk with multiple Blueprints
inside of your level.
Then we're going to move on to basically combining
all of the knowledge that we've just gone over in sections
1, 2, and 3 by creating a light switch that
will be able to control lights that
are placed in the level.
And then we'll further extend that light switch on your own
to allow it to control multiple lights.
So let's go ahead and get started
with our object-oriented concepts.